Kipchoge Keino, aka Hezekiah Kipchoge Keino
or (thankfully in the interest of avoiding
typos) just Kip, is a retired athlete who
ran for the country of Kenya.
Throughout his career, Kip earned almost a
dozen medals, half of which were gold, for
being an amazing middle to long distance runner.
The story we want to share is the time Kip
was almost late for his own race and had to
(literally) run to get there, then won a gold
medal anyway, despite another major adversity
in that race, which we’ll get to in a minute.
First, a little info on the man himself, because
he’s awesome.
We’ll start with his name.
Kipchoge is a Nandi expression for something
to the effect of “born near the grain storage
shed.”
If you guessed he came from humble beginnings,
you’d be right.
Things didn’t get better when both of his
parents died when he was very young; he then
moved in with his aunt who raised him.
When once asked about his childhood and how
he got started running, this was Kip’s response:
When I started at primary school.
I ran in my bare feet four miles to school
in the morning, home for lunch, again for
afternoon school and back at the end of the
day.
I did this every day until I left school
If your mind is still trying to work out the
maths for that one, Kip ran 16 miles every
single day in Kenyan heat without shoes just
to get to school- Kip managed this starting
as a 5 year old.
You may think that with this impressive running
ability, Kip was destined to be a runner.
After finishing school, though, he didn’t
immediately get into competitive running.
Instead, Kip became a physical training instructor
for the Kenyan police force.
At the time, Kenya was not the runner generating
powerhouse it is today.
In fact, Kip was one of the first great runners
the country produced.
It wasn’t until the early 1960s that Kip
realised that his thighs demanded a greater
challenge and he took up competitive athletics
on the side from his day job.
Though Kip was ultimately one of the finest
distance runners of his time- perhaps one
of the finest of all time- he didn’t achieve
significant results until the 1964 Tokyo Olympics,
where he narrowly missed qualifying for the
1500M final.
A year later, in 1965, Kip broke two distance
running world records (the 1500M and 5000M
events respectively) at the 1965 All-Africa
Games.
A year after that impressive feat, during
the 1966 commonwealth games, Kip won a double
gold in the mile and three mile sprint events.
His greatest feat came two years later during
the 1968 Olympics in Mexico City.
We say “greatest feat” because for the
entire duration of the games, Kip was suffering
from crippling gallstones.
And we mean crippling- Kip literally collapsed
while running the 10,000M. This was especially
cruel when you realise that Kip was in the
lead when the pain overwhelmed him and he
had only three laps to go!
By stepping off of the track after he collapsed,
he’d automatically disqualified himself.
Determined to finish the race anyway, he stumbled
back onto the track and, despite the pain,
managed to do the final laps, even though
it didn’t count.
The eventual winner of that race was one,
Naftali Temu, another Kenyan who now holds
the honor of being Kenya’s first gold medal
winner.
An honor that almost went to Kip.
Now this is where the story gets interesting.
Prior to running the 10,000M, Kip had been
told by a doctor not to run and that any strain
to his body was at risk of causing him serious
harm, and in the extreme case could even lead
to his death.
Of course, Kip ran anyway as noted.
Two days after the 10,000M- the race he collapsed
in- Kip ran in the 5000M and won a silver
medal, finishing just one fifth of a second
behind the gold medalist.
On top of that, he then ran another 1500M
race and qualified for the final of the event.
At this point, you may think Kip was tempting
fate, but we’re still not done.
The day of 1500M final, Kip, presumably due
to the fact that HE HAD GALLSTONES, elected
to sleep in and there was some thought that
he was simply choosing not to race that day
when his absence was noticed, given the day
before he had indicated he might not given
his medical problem.
Nevertheless, only an hour before the actual
event, he hopped out of bed and headed off
to the games.
On the bus ride to the Olympic stadium, the
bus became stuck in traffic and this is where
the story gets interesting.
Realising the bus was going to be late, Kip
got off and ran the remaining 2 miles to the
Olympic stadium while carrying his equipment.
He then registered with 20 minutes to spare,
got himself ready, and walked out onto the
track and won a gold medal, outpacing the
second place runner by an astounding 20 metres-
the longest distance anyone had ever won by
in the event at that time.
(And possibly even to this day as far as I
can find- though don’t quote me on that,
as I didn’t go through every Olympics from
then to now.
I just wasn’t able to find any record of
a greater lead from my research in the 1500M.)
Not only this, the man he beat by such a huge
margin, Jim Ryun, had not been defeated in
the 1,500M in three years.
Further, Kip had now raced five times in that
Olympics, while Ryun was completely fresh.
And, of course, that’s not to mention the
gallstones.
In the end, Kip finished with a time of 3:34.9,
the second fastest in history at that point.
To put that in slightly more common terms,
that’s a pace of 25.13 km/hr or 15.61 mph
for 1500 metres!
Seriously, go watch the race here and realise
that not only is Kip running with a constant
stabbing pain in his abdomen, but that he
had just ran 2 miles to the stadium in sweltering
Mexican heat.
Then, feel angry when you scroll down and
see that the video’s description is “Jim
Ryun wins the silver medal at the 1968 Olympics“-
surely Kip’s victory was a little more noteworthy,
eh, YouTube poster?
After this victory, Kip went on to win several
more medals before eventually settling down
in Kenya, where he currently runs a charity
for orphans, as well as helped found a primary
and a secondary school.
For his many humanitarian works in his post-professional
career, he was inducted into the World Sports
Humanitarian Hall of Fame.